how's it going everybody it's warren
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
blender where we talk all things marvel
and
everything relating to the marvel
cinematic universe and today we have
some more
unexpected black panther 2 news and this
time it's coming from a marvel executive
vice president
now the last thing that we really heard
about black panther 2 was that it was
possible that marvel studios was
considering
a cgi chadwick bozeman for just a very
short part of the film in the very
beginning
and then in the beginning of the movie
black panther would die in battle
now this thought was pretty
controversial for a pretty good reason
chadwick has sadly passed away in real
life and we don't need to mourn it again
and go through it again in the movie
even if it's an off-screen death
however it does seem like black panther
may already be dead
in the mcu according to marvel's
executive vice president
she did an interview very recently where
she talked about what they're going to
do with black panther 2 and i'll break
it all down in this video
but first if you're new be sure to
subscribe so you can stay up to date on
all the latest mcu news and so you can
enter this week's giveaway for a chance
to win a tony stark avengers in game
funko pop and shout out to
heroeshideout.com for providing this
funko you can go to their website they
have a ton of awesome
marvel merch so like i said marvel's
executive vice president victoria alonso
recently did an interview with an
argentinian journal
she was asked about black panther 2 and
she had something very
very interesting to say they asked
what's going to happen
with black panther 2 and she says there
were talks about creating a cgi
bozeman no there's only one chadwick and
he's no longer with us
and here's the really fascinating part
she says
unfortunately our king is dead not only
in fiction but also in real life
that line right there she just said that
the king
black panther is dead in fiction
implying that he
is in fact dead in the mcu and i'll come
back to this in just a bit but i'll
finish what she said in the interview
she continues by saying we are taking
our time to think how are we going to
continue that story
and what are we going to do to honor
this chapter and
this unexpected and terrible death in
production
sometimes two or three months are enough
and you say time has passed
but this is not the case we need to
think what are we going to do
how are we going to honor the franchise
so marvel studios is still taking their
time
rightfully so but the comment about our
king is dead
not only in fiction but in real life
suggests that t'challa
is dead in the mcu and what this
probably means is we won't be seeing any
type of on-screen death no cgi
no nothing in fact when the movie starts
it will probably pay a tribute to not
only chadwick boseman but t'challa
as well and then from there they'll move
on and a new black panther will come
into play
now it has already been confirmed that
shuri is making or has already made
within the marvel cinematic universe a
new synthetic heart-shaped herb one that
has vibranium inside of it
so whenever it's time for the next
ceremony and the next black panther to
come in
they will in fact get their powers from
a new heart-shaped herb despite the fact
that killmonger managed to destroy
pretty much every heart-shaped herb but
one and there's been a lot of talk about
shuri becoming the new black panther
this has happened in the comics before
and this does seem like a fairly decent
option but like marvel's executive vice
president said
as of right now nothing has really been
decided or at least nothing is set in
stone
but for now we know that they're not
going to do a cgi chadwick bozeman
but it sounds like from the very
beginning when the second black panther
film starts
t'challa may actually already have
passed away again the line the king is
dead in fiction
and in real life pretty much says that
t'challa is actually currently dead in
the marvel cinematic universe as well it
just happened off screen and they'll
explain it in black panther too now i'm
sure this is being done to honor
chadwick boseman in the best way
possible
we don't need to see his death on screen
we don't need to see
his family in the mcu finding out about
his death on screen
instead we'll do our best to remember
him and they'll give him a tribute in
the movie that he deserves
but do you agree with this what would
you like to see happen
and are you okay with shuri becoming the
next black panther or would you like to
see somebody else take on that mantle
let me know down below and be sure to
subscribe so you can stay up to date on
all the latest things happening within
the mcu including black panther 2.
don't forget to like the video and for
live updates you can follow me on
instagram and twitter
don't forget to check out heroes
hideout.com for some awesome mcu merch
and as always thank you all so much for
watching
woof
you